all right so check this out you guys
remember this little camera the insta
360 go it's super small and portable but
guess what it now comes in a beautiful
matte black color and I'm so excited
about this because these little cameras
are some of my favorite so this shoots
photos and video up to 2.7k with Flow
State stabilization it has voice control
and it's waterproof up to 5 m but most
importantly this new insta 360 go 3
version has this housing that lets you
magnetically and also wirelessly connect
to it for a flip up screen so it's
easier to view record and change
settings when you remove the camera the
housing acts as an external monitor so
you can view exactly what your camera is
seeing all of these accessories let you
mount it in such unique ways because of
how small it is this lets you get super
cool shots that otherwise would be quite
a challenge the other thing that I love
is it has this little necklace accessory
and because this is magnetic you can use
this to magnetically attach the camera
to your shirt and you can get really
cool firstperson views you can stick it
to anything else that's
magnetic okay that's not magnetic you
know what I mean